Traductor: Sebastian Betti
Revisor: Gisela Giardino
A mí los insectos
me apasionan por dos cosas.
Por un lado, me vuelve loca
la diversidad infinita
de este tipo de pequeños seres.
Treinta millones;
no de insectos, de especies.
Nosotros decimos que
"los humanos inventamos la rueda".
Los escarabajos peloteros trasladaban
bolas de estiercol
muchísimo antes de que a nosotros
se nos ocurriera siquiera pararnos.
"Los humanos inventamos el abono".
Las hormigas hacían compost
bastante antes de que lo hiciera
cualquier ecologista en su balcón.
Y si por casualidad Uds. pensaban
que hemos inventado
"el aire acondicionado",
están absolutamente equivocados.
Por supuesto que las termitas
lo han hecho primero.
Y hasta hay algunos que
sirven como termómetros.
Se los presento: los grillos.
Cuanto más crics hacen,
mayor es la temperatura ambiente.
Obviamente varía según las especies,
pero es bastante preciso.
Y estos son solo algunos datos
de cuatro insectos.
Imagínense todo esto multiplicado
por 30 millones.
Increíble.
(Risas)
Además, los insectos son riquísimos.
Y esa era la segunda cosa
que les quería contar.
(Aplausos)
A los 11 años me encontraba
comiendo una hamburguesa
en una cadena de comida rápida
cuando un niño se me acerca y me dice:
"¿Sabías que las hamburguesas
están hechas de insectos?"
"Pará, bancá.
¿Los insectos se pueden comer?"
Después me enteré de que lo de
las hamburguesas era todo un mito
pero en su momento me quedé
muy intrigada y me lo puse a investigar.
Y efectivamente los insectos
no solo se pueden comer,
sino que además tienen
muchísimas ventajas.
En comparación con las producciones
agrícola y ganadera
generan más alimento en menos espacio
y utilizando menos recursos naturales.
Una vaca que pastorea necesita
aproximadamente una hectárea para moverse.
Mientras que los insectos no necesitan
más lugar del que ya ocupan.
Ahora, si a esa vaca que pastorea
se le da de comer 8 kg de alimento,
genera aproximadamente 1 kg
de carne vacuna; ocho en uno.
Mientras que si le doy esos mismos
8 kg de alimento a los insectos
me generan 4 kg; ocho en cuatro.
Encima los insectos, en general, tienen
más proteína cada 100 g que nuestra vaca.
Por darles un ejemplo, los grillos
tienen un 22 % más de proteína.
Y como si eso no fuera suficiente,
la producción ganadera es responsable
del 37 % del metano emitido
por la actividad humana
que contribuye al efecto invernadero.
Y, ¿adivinen qué?
Los insectos emiten entre diez
y cien veces menos
que, por ejemplo, los cerdos.
Bueno, bárbaro, pero si los
insectos son tan geniales,
¿por qué no están en las góndolas
de todos los supermercados?
Precisamente por las caras
que pusieron todas y todos Uds.
cuando me comí recién el grillo.
Nosotros acá no lo tenemos tan presente,
pero en el mundo hoy
hay 2000 millones de personas
que comen insectos habitualmente.
Como latinoamericanos hasta
no hace tanto también lo hacíamos.
Nuestra dieta precolombina contaba con
una variedad importantísima de insectos:
Larvas de hormiga, gusanos, grillos, etc.
Hasta que llegaron los españoles
y pusieron la misma cara que Uds.
Probablemente cuando piensen
en comer un insecto,
se imaginen mordiendo
una cucaracha así
o cortando con un cuchillo
una tarántula de este tamaño,
pero no habéis de temer.
Un producto que se está empezando
a comercializar mucho
es la harina de insecto.
Tiene todos los beneficios
que les mencioné antes
sumado a que ni te das cuenta
de que te estás comiendo grillos
en una porción de pan.
Entonces, ¿qué hacemos para aprovechar
más lo que nos dan los insectos?
En 2017, junto a un grupo
de amigos, fuimos a Chile.
A la Primera Cumbre Latinoamericana
de Líderes Jóvenes en Biotecnología.
Ahí propusimos una idea
que creo que puede ayudar.
Propusimos crear insectos para producir
alimento con valor agregado
en zonas urbanas como solución
a la falta de espacio
y al costo de los recursos.
Hicimos esto porque si las y los jóvenes
no derribamos estas barreras culturales,
no lo va hacer nadie.
De hecho, ya lo estamos haciendo
con las cuestiones de género.
Y además, en Latinoamérica,
la producción de alimentos
es una parte central de nuestra economía
y no podemos quedarnos atrás
frente a estos cambios.
Y para esto no es necesario
tener un galpón gigante
o hacer grandes inversiones.
Yo, por ejemplo, intento aportar
mi granito de arena en mi casa
criando insectos,
estudiando cómo prepararlos
y cómo transformarlos para que
se haga más fácil su consumo.
¿Y si vemos a los insectos
más allá de nuestros prejuicios?
¿Y si los vemos como termómetros,
como grandes inventores,
pero también como comida?
La naturaleza nos provee una solución
rentable, viable, sustentable
y, encima, rica.
Aprovechémosla y tratemos de cambiar
la cara con la que vemos a los insectos.
(Aplausos)